the new york times now admits that the
hunter biden laptop is real the
washington post admits that the hunter
biden laptop is real lots and lots of
establishment media are admitting that
it's real which means that hunters
meticulously recorded crimes are real
which means that the crooked deals with
enemy governments
are real which means that in some of
those crooked deals with the enemy
governments the 10 percent being held
for the big guy joe biden is almost
certainly real
which is to borrow a phrase from joe
biden a big effing deal but some people
in the liberal establishment media still
don't want to admit it
thank you for doing this really
appreciate it i'm daniel schmidt i'm a
freshman at the university of chicago my
question is for miss applebaum so in
2020 you wrote those who live outside
the fox news bubble do not of course
need to learn any of this stuff about
hunter biden referring to his laptop of
curse a poll later after that found that
if voters knew about the content of the
laptop 16 of joe biden voters would have
acted differently now of course we know
a few weeks ago the new york times
confirmed that the content is real do
you think the media acted
inappropriately when they instantly
dismissed uh hunter biden's laptop as
russian disinformation and what can we
learn from that and ensuring that what
we label as this information is truly
this information
and not
reality
my problem with hunter biden's laptop is
i think totally irrelevant i mean it's
not whether it's disinformation or i
mean i don't think the
hunter biden's
business relationships have anything to
do with who should be president of the
united states so
i i didn't find i don't find it to be
interesting i mean that that would be my
problem with that as a as a major news
story
it's not interesting
you can say a lot of things about the
hunter biden laptop
but uh crack pipes hookers
seven figure bribes from foreign
governments that's
i think we all would have to agree that
is at least
interesting
more to the point this is not a major
news story we're talking about what
appears to be from all the available
evidence perhaps the most egregious
financial corruption in the history of
the united states
that's not a major news story no it's
not a major news story to the writers
and editors who are carrying for
carrying water for joe biden yeah it's
not to them but if you're just looking
at the news of course it's a major news
story it implicates not just hunter
biden it implicates joe too and cbs news
is finally admitting it cbs news has a
big report on this they say quote
cbs has learned more than 150 financial
transactions involving either hunter or
james biden that's joe's brother
their global affairs business were
flagged as concerning by u.s banks for
further review some of those concerns
included large wire transfers now some
people in the liberal establishment
press still don't want to come clean
about
all of the work they've done to cover up
for joe biden they still want to stick
to the story but frankly what is more
interesting to me is the growing number
of major establishment liberal outlets
that are coming clean all at the same
time the times the washington post cbs
news
seems to me joe biden's not getting any
respect these days not from obama the
other day at the white house not from
the white house staff and not even
from the press anymore
all of the dirt all of the mud that
we've known about if you've been
listening to this show that we've known
about for years all of it's just coming
up now does this mean perhaps that the
big guy's political time is up
did you like that clip i'm glad go
subscribe ring the bell get the
notifications also head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify or stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]